alright guys so the lego movie hey hey I
heard you just saw my movie so so what'd
you think of it what you think of it yes
I did just see your movie actually yeah
yeah so you're gonna get a good grade
huh you gotta give it an A+ gonna give
A+ I don't know I may not have liked it
what you've gotta be kidding me look if
you keep bugging me throughout this
whole review I'm gonna take you
hairpiece and I'm gonna throw it
somewhere where you can't find it yeah
you got a big I'm just gonna be over
here partying with Batman and Catwoman
the lego movie the first time I heard of
this I thought wow that's just a new
shameless way to get children to buy
your products man was I wrong the lego
movie is about this prophecy this
foretold where this one special
extremely interesting man can save the
world from the villainous Will Ferrell
who's also known as Lord business he has
some ancient relic called the crackle
that can kill every Lego in Lego
universe and the one guy that is
prophesied to be able to stop this from
happening is Emmitt voiced by Chris
Pratt all these people are trying to
convince him that he's this one special
person that can save the entire Lego
universe but he is used to following
instructions following orders doing
everything by the book and he doesn't
realize the true nature of his world the
lego movie is the first great movie of
2014 this movie really surprised me on
virtually every level it's extremely
clever and the thing about it that I was
so impressed with was just how much
humor it was actually able to create out
of basic Lego things like if you went
out and bought a Lego set and it came
with instructions those are the
instructions that the Legos use to go
about their daily lives and there are
countless other awesome things that are
extremely inventive that really just
blew my mind this is one of the greatest
animations I've seen in a while
it's supposed to look entirely like
stop-motion animation and some of it
definitely is but they also use CGI to
blend it but they didn't make it look
like realistic backgrounds everything in
this movie looks like a Lego piece and
that is so cool because I grew up
playing with Legos you know my dad and I
used to build little towns and cities
and all different types of things and we
had these little imaginary adventures
with Legos when we were kids when I was
a kid my dad wasn't a kid he was an
adult he worked my dad was a kid all
right anyway so there's definitely that
aspect of it that really connects with
me but it's not just that is not
just the coolness of seeing Lego ships
and seeing little lego people fight and
have laser wars with realistic little
lego laser things that look like
lightsabers this movie really pokes fun
at genre cliches and the conventions of
your normal Hollywood movie tons of
jokes that your average kid is not going
to understand until he's into his teens
and a lot of in jokes for people who
watch a lot of movies and you understand
the cliches of your average movie
because this movie pokes fun at all of
that and it does it in such a clever way
that it continued to surprise me
throughout almost every minute of this
movie this is a really fast-paced comedy
a lot of jokes fly by really fast and if
you're not paying attention you're going
to miss some of them their filmmakers
respect the audience enough to think
that yes they are listening to every
little thing that comes out of these
characters mouths and if you pay
attention this movie closely you're
going to get a lot of great gems of
humor and I got to say that's really
refreshing because it's so rare to walk
into a movie that might generally be
looked at as a kids film and realize it
is so much smarter than you thought it
was going to be all the characters in
the film are really likable and really
fun especially the main character Emmett
he's this guy who you know it's kind of
like that cliched I don't know who I am
what's my place in the world oh I'm the
one on the special guy yes we've seen
that before but as I said this movie
makes fun of the fact that we've seen
that type of plot before and that's one
of the things I loved about this movie
was that it said yes this is a very
common trope in this type of film where
there's some sort of mystical fantasy
some prophecy to be fulfilled we've seen
it in Star Wars we've seen it in the
Matrix this movies like we know you've
seen that before we know you're sick and
tired of it we think it's hilarious and
we're going to find ways to make it
hilarious and they really do and of
course this movie has Batman in it and
it's awesome how can you go wrong with
Lego Batman you can't it is so funny
they just find all these little pop
culture things and they find the
cheesiest dumbest elements of it and
bring it out the voice work is top-notch
everyone is giving great performances
but one of the ones I was most impressed
with was actually Liam Neeson as bad cop
he was great in the film this movie also
had a very surprising heartwarming pull
to it which took me off guard I gotta
say this is the first great movie of
2014 it feels like it should be coming
out in the summer but hey we get it now
it's very refreshing to see a movie
that's actually good in theaters thank
you lego movie I'm going to give you an
A my
so guys if you are a fan of American
Psycho like I am I bought this shirt off
my friend the flick pic he made it it's
for sale on his RedBubble site I'm
supporting him if you'd like to support
him too you can check out the link below
and let him know that I sent you to
check out his shirts because he's got
some cool designs this is my favorite
one I was like wow dude I have to have
this guy's thanks so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes